[Applaudissements]
toujours papa sur la grille condamné
c'est vrai tout ça mais je m'en suis
débarrassé lancé un chien labrador s'est
pas passée très fidèle à son papa d'une
petite fille touchée
moi je suis toujours un homme très bien
est en fait j'ai pas si vous avez
remarqué mais il a été une chanson pour
vous vous avez entendu ou pas j'ai
entendu boulleville ouais c'est ça alors
un peu juste écouter mais vraiment comme
ça on acoustic on peut la faire en
acoustique
[Musique]
son trait
audi
là
il est sans talent fait chier sur les
paroles alors et là c'est un mec qui se
casse pas le coeur à non alors l'amener
en abondance
[Applaudissements]